the number of coronavirus cases is
increasing across the country Saturday
alone there were more than 25,000 new
coronavirus cases reported in the US
yesterday New York's Governor Andrew
Cuomo threatened to reverse reopening
zin areas where large numbers of people
are violating social distancing orders
dr. David agus joins us with how to stay
safe this summer David good morning I've
noticed over the weekend that that
people are still being really careful if
they're inside but much more Cavalier
outside I saw a line outside a reopen
coffee shop where everybody was wearing
masks but they were all on top of each
other if you're going outside now what
do you need to take into consideration
you know America seems done with the
corona virus but the corona virus isn't
done with America it's still here so
when you go out of doors wearing a mask
is critical so you can't spread the
virus unknowingly to others and
obviously social distancing where you go
matters should be going to an area where
there are lots of people you probably
want to avoid and go to never worry
there less people playing your day so
it's not going to be in a crowded area
where you could be exposed so if you're
looking to have a picnic or a backyard
gathering what do you do so first of all
you're gonna have a picnic you don't
choose where to go strategically don't
go to the center of the park where
everybody is go to the periphery where
you can have space look who you're
having it with you know we all have
friends that take more risk and some
that take less risk so you need to know
your personal risk tolerance do you live
with a grandmother who's elderly or have
somebody with medical conditions in your
house versus not you identify your risk
have it out of doors is critical the
virus spreads much less out of doors
because there's much more ventilation
there and set up the area in advance so
there's your area and there's the people
that you're visiting with their area and
they're at least 6 feet apart really
critical that that planning is done
is it safe David to serve food at these
events and if you and if you're at one
of these gatherings
should you feel safe to eat well first
of all if you ain't serving food at a
picnic you got an issue there yeah it's
it's good to say it's a serve food
the key is you know as much as possible
keep it cold food it's this summer it's
a hot food if it's left out for a while
can have issues each of you package in
advance your own food so if you're going
with another family each of you bring
separate food and you know structure it
so you don't have to share utensils and
then you will have a nice time visiting
with each other when you're not eating
wear masks and social distance when you
are eating and it will be a safe
gathering what about the beach David
which is where a lot of people are dying
to head there now what should we
consider in going to the beach you know
it's the same thing is that you want to
go in an area where you can social
distance so have your blanket with your
family and go to an area where you can
have distance from others the amount of
time you interact with somebody directly
correlates to the risk of getting a
virus so if you're an area that's very
crowded and you're gonna interact for a
significant period of time with a lot of
people that's not good so choose the
periphery choose the not as crowded
Beach maybe it's a longer Drive but at
the end you'll be more relaxed and it'll
be a safer visit go in the water and
have fun
some parents David are considering
whether to send their kids to camp
what's your advice on that well that's a
big decision
some families you just have to send
their kids to camp so they can do their
work or get back to their business or
their life working outside of the home
you know there's a study from the
Netherlands that's critical that showed
that children - children spread is rare
and children to adult spread is rare
much more common adult to adult or adult
to a child so you know children
themselves are obviously much lower risk
of getting sick or significantly sick
from the virus but at Camp you got to
make sure the cabin has ventilation that
drop-off times are staggered you don't
want to be there with every other adult
trying to cram things into the
children's bunks we're dropping off the
children at the same time if it's a day
camp the key is to be strategic
yeah well not many camp cabins that I've
seen have a lot of ventilation David
thank you